elle est dans ce contexte les hôtels
sont aussi victimes de la crise
tourisme en berne et clientèle
d'affaires absente les 18000 hôtelier de
france sont en souffrance
le taux d'occupation actuel
historiquement bas à 13 4% n'est pas
pour rassurer un secteur en pleine
déprime
mais si on y regarde de plus près les
situations sont très différentes d'un
type d'établissement à l'autre reportage
dans un hôtel d'affaires 2 étoiles à
saint pierre des corps et dans un quatre
étoiles de tourisme à esvres hélène
chapelet
sur les trente et une chambre de cet
hôtel restaurant deux étoiles de saint
pierre des corps en semaine seule une
dizaine sont régulièrement occupées pour
stéphane qui a racheté les lieux en 2003
il a donc fallu s'adapter
ses huit salariés sont au chômage
partiel et désormais c'est lui qui fait
le ménage dans les chambres et qui
prépare les petits déjeuners servis dans
les étages à cause du télétravail et de
la fermeture de son restaurant il a
perdu près de 65 % de son chiffre
d'affaires actuellement j'ai une
clientèle beaucoup de commerciaux
d'entreprises de saint pierre des corps
en fin de compte en banque dans le btp
la sncf beaucoup dans le ferroviaire et
tout ce qui est en fin de compte le
transport routier
j'ai à peu près entre sept et huit mille
euros hors taxes des rentrées de chiffre
d'affaires par mois en hôtellerie et
petit déjeuner et j'ai à peu près entre
15 et 18 mille euros de charges fixes
tous les mois malgré les dix mille euros
d' aide mensuelle du gouvernement
stéphane doit donc puisé chaque mois
dans sa trésorerie pour se verser un
salaire de l'argent qu'il ne pourra plus
mettre dans la rénovation de son
établissement
autre lieu autre réalité dans ce 4
étoiles situé à esvres pour la saint
valentin les 18 lodge ont tous été
réservés
l'hôtel qui a ouvert en juillet dernier
n'a jamais eu la clientèle qui
l'attendait pas de touristes étrangers
mais une majorité de moins de 35 ans
issue de la région parisienne ou du
département malgré la conjoncture
ici on atteint les week-ends 60 à 65 %
de taux d'occupation en termes de taux
de remplissage
on va pas se plaindre
c'est pas au delà de nos objectifs mais
on arrive tant bien que mal en
travaillant beaucoup et en s'adaptant à
maintenir à peu près
notre business plan malgré tout et on
reconnaît que sans les aides de l'état
ce serait quand même beaucoup plus
difficile parce que le chômage partiel
nous aident à piloter au jour le jour
nos équipes par rapport à la clientèle
qu'on peut trouver depuis le début de
l'épidémie les 18000 hôtels recensés en
france connaissent tous des situations
très diverses
chez nous les professionnels attendent
avec impatience la réouverture des
châteaux pour espérer retrouver un peu
plus de clientèle